there's jordan montgomery
he's got five pitches coming off a
victory on tuesday
against the atlanta braves lard drags
one to the left side for torres
and they didn't make the tag so pilar
safe at first
luke voight with the catch in the air
but pilar
speed he gets to first and he's got an
infield hit yeah torres is going to be a
little disappointed in that
pilar on first after the torres error
and jd martinez also
off to a slow start
and that's to torres and a chance for
two turn easily
after a pair of ground ball outs martin
perez has loaded up the bases
that's full for anduha and he rips one
to left
peraza gives it a look and he's got room
up against the wall
second time through the order for the
yankees starting with hicks 2-2 runners
on the move
picks going the other way and that's
gonna find some open space and score a
run
tyler wade come on down aaron hicks with
an rbi double the yankees
break the ice double number six on the
year for hicks that puts a runner in
scoring
position for luke voight who owns the
second highest career slugging
percentage against the red sox
in major league history oh boy
sends one a long way to left center
and pilar heading back forget about it
he belongs on that list
with the greats against boston
when you are among the greats against
the red sox
you want to keep it that way that was
right down broadway
voigt didn't miss it do you see native
of panama
down on strikes that's a tidy first time
through the order
for jordan montgomery martinez on second
bogart's at first a couple singles
chip shot shallow left center and it's
dropped
and that's gonna bring home a run for
the red sox martinez comes in
and it's three to one oh oh look what's
coming
yeah the red sox snag a run just before
the raindrops come calling tarp on the
field they'll pause this game
yankees leading 3-1 in the fourth inning
it's been
80 minutes and the bases are full of red
sox
verdugo will dig in
that's a big pitch got him on a bad one
the socks leave him loaded there's joss
osich on the mound
for boston taking over for martine perez
tyrostrata is going to send it to left
center
heading back forget about it tyro
estrada muscles up for the first time
this year and the yankees lead it four
to one
when we spoke to aaron boone a few hours
ago we said
fill us in on tyro estrada because with
that next man up mentality
i'm sure he's gonna do something special
so now it's the
23 year old devers
on the ground and a chance to turn two
torres throw
money this time following the strike to
luke voight
who homered back in the second
go long luke floyd
has a two home run game he muscles up
again that's
seven on the season it's five one
yankees
trouble off the bat and it left in a
curry yep
another one of those no doubters as a as
a pitcher sometimes you don't even look
at the outfield fence you just
look at the umpire and say give me a new
one two on two outs
team trailing by a few runs
and he goes the other way backing up and
do hard he doesn't play it and it hops
over the wall for a ground rule double
he's learning the position out there and
verdugo takes advantage
the red sox strike again it's 5-2 see
austin bryce coming on
kevin pawecki new catcher to take over
that first pitch is smacked
destroyed aaron hicks off the facing of
the second deck
his second home run of the season it's
6-2
bombers and welcome to yankee stadium
austin bryce this
get loud if you're a yankee fan or aldis
chapman is back
that's a combination of power and
control you want coming out of the
bullpen
takes the slider to left and connects
it's a fair ball
peraza comes home and the red sox get a
run off
chapman in his debut arauw slides in
safely to second with the rbi double
there's the heater chapman has his first
strikeout of 2020.
here comes a young robbie devers
and he does the damage they need him to
keep this one alive
no way chapman challenges
a little stare game over yankees take
down the red sox
6-3